- [Voiceover] Metal-air cells
are a relatively new type
of portable energy source
consisting of a metal anode,
an alkaline electrolyte
paste that contains water
and a porous cathode
membrane that lets in oxygen
from the air.
A schematic of the cell is
shown above, and so we see
the different parts right over here,
we see the metal anode, it's an anode.
So this would be the negative
terminal of our power source.
It'll be the source of electrons.
We have an alkaline electrolyte
paste that contains water.
Let me underline that,
there's a lot of interesting
words there.
Alkaline electrolyte
paste that contains water.
That's this right over here in the middle.
When they say it's alkaline,
that means that it's going
to be basic versus acidic.
It's going to have a pH higher than seven.
Electrolyte paste.
An electrolyte is something
that if you dissolve it
in a polar substance, a
polar substance like water,
well then the solution is going to be good
at conducting electricity.
So what they tell us,
this electrolyte paste
is gonna be something that's
good at conducting electricity,
and they tell us it's alkaline,
so it's going to be basic.
It's going to have a pH higher than seven.
And a porous cathode
membrane that let's in oxygen
from the air.
So this is the cathode,
this is going to be
the positive terminal.
This is where the electrons
are going to be attracted to,
and it's a porous cathode
membrane that lets in oxygen
from the air.
And so you can see that
oxygen is available
in this membrane.
It somehow is allowed to seep in
because it is porous.
Reduction potentials for the
cathode and three possible
metal anodes are given in the table below.
So remember, reduction potentials,
you can view these.
Reduction is the gaining
of electrons.
So this is the potential
to gain electrons,
is one way to think about it,
or a reaction that
somehow involves electrons
being incorporated in some way.
And right over here you
have molecular oxygen
reacting with water.
For every molecule of molecular oxygen,
you get two molecules of water.
Four electrons, and
then they react to form
four hydroxide anions.
So once again, this is
a reduction reaction
because those electrons
are being incorporated
into the molecule.
And so you're left with the
hydroxide right over here.
And if you look at our
metal air cell up here,
where is that occurring?
Well, you need oxygen, you need water
and you need electrons.
Well, if you look at the
cathode right over here,
you got your electrons coming in,
you got your oxygen coming
in, and water, we can assume,
is available in this area.
The electrolyte paste has water in it.
The cathode is porous,
it's a porous membrane-type substance.
So they're all available over here.
So you can assume that, that reaction
could happen right over
here in the cathode.
So let me just write it, 02 in as a gas.
So for every molecule of O2,
you're gonna have two molecules
of H2O in a liquid form.
And then you got your electrons
coming in on the wire,
I guess you could say,
and that is going to yield
four hydroxide anions.
Four hydroxide anions.
And they're in a solution.
They're part of that electrolyte
paste that's in water.
They're an aqueous solution,
a water-based solution.
And so that's going to
happen right over there
so the hydroxide anions,
I can even say four hydroxide anions
are going to be produced
every time this reaction
is happening.
And they tell us the reduction potential.
This has a positive potential,
has a positive voltage.
And notice they say the
reduction potential at pH 11.
So that's consistent
with alkaline conditions
because this paste might seep
in through here a little bit
and obviously you have all
this hydroxide being produced.
So you're gonna have a
higher pH, a more basic pH.
And so the fact that this
is a positive voltage,
so plus 0.34 volts
means that the potential
is going in this direction.
The electric potential favors
this reaction to happen
going from left to right.
Now they also said they give
us the reduction potentials
for the cathode, which
we just talked about,
this is the reduction
potential for the cathode,
and three possible metal anodes are given
in the table below.
So here there are three
possible metal anodes.
So we could have zinc,
we could have sodium,
we could have calcium,
and so let's just go with
zinc since it's the first one
listed here.
So if we assumed that
the metal here was zinc,
what's going to be going on?
Well, you're going to
have the zinc reacting
with these hydroxides
that are being produced
over in the cathode, and
then you're going to use that
to produce zinc oxide water and electrons.
So you're actually gonna have
the reverse of this reaction.
You're going to have,
let me write the reverse.
You're going to have
zinc in the solid state.
This whole anode is
made out of metal zinc.
And then for every molecule of that,
you're gonna have two hydroxide
anions that are dissolved
in water.
That's what makes the
electrolyte paste alkaline.
And you are going to then go to,
they're going to react and
you're going to form zinc oxide.
Zinc oxide in the solid state,
plus water
in the liquid state,
plus two, plus two electrons.
And so this reaction
that I just described,
this is going to be
happening right over here.
So you could think of it
as the hydroxide anions
get formed at the cathode,
and then they move their way
over to the left to the anode
where they react with the zinc
and they turn, or the zinc
reacts and forms zinc oxide,
so you have more and more
zinc oxide being formed,
water, which can then
seep its way back into
the electrolyte paste and
then it can eventually
react again at the cathode,
and then you have these two electrons.
So these electrons, this
turns into an electron source
right over here, and then
the electrons would migrate
and then they can go to the
positive side, the cathode,
to react again.
And so you can start
to see how this will be
an energy source that you
can tap into this current
that'll form to do some useful work.
That's why you have an energy source.
All right, so let's
read that questions now
that we have a decent
understanding of what's going on.
Early forms of metal air
cells use zinc as the anode.
Well, that's the example
we just thought about.
Zinc oxide is produced
as the cell operates
according to the overall equation below.
For every two molecules of zinc
and one molecule of molecular oxygen,
you produce two molecules of zinc oxide.
Use the data in the table above,
calculate the cell potential
for the zinc air cell.
So let's think about, let's
break down this reaction.
Actually, we can just break it down
into these two steps here.
Because notice, this is,
we can't see them both at the same time
but this, the things that are reacting,
you have zinc.
Let me underlie the
things that are reacting.
You have zinc, you have zinc.
You have oxygen, you have oxygen.
And so if you return this,
if you return the second reaction around
like we did before, and let me rewrite it,
let me rewrite both of them
actually a little bit lower
right over here.
So you have this top reaction.
So you have O2 gaseous state plus two
H2O liquid, plus four electrons.
Whoops, four electrons,
yields four hydroxide anions
in aqueous solution.
And then this one, we said we're gonna go
in the other direction.
So you're going to have zinc,
you're going to have zinc
in the solid state,
plus two hydroxide anions.
And then that's going to yield zinc,
zinc oxide in the solid state,
plus liquid water
plus two electrons.
So when you see this, you
see that we are reacting,
we have the oxygen, we have the zinc,
which are the two things
(mumbles) interact here.
And if you want to make them equivalent
in terms of the number of molecules,
we could say all right,
we have one molecule of molecular oxygen
and we need two zincs.
So let me multiply this
whole reaction by two.
So two zincs react with four hydroxides,
react to produce two zinc oxides,
two molecules of water,
and then four electrons.
I just said, well, if this
reaction happened twice,
you'd would have just twice
as many of the reactants
and the products here.
And then notice, now you have
a molecule of molecular oxygen,
two molecules of zinc,
molecule of molecular oxygen,
two molecules of zinc.
If all of this were to happen,
you are going to produce
two molecules of zinc oxide.
And well, what about
everything else that I put,
that were in these reactions?
Well, the water is here,
but then water also gets
two modules of water,
two molecules of water.
So I guess if you look
at the total reaction,
we're neutral there, we haven't
produced or lost any water.
You have four electrons,
you have four electrons.
So that's why they didn't write it
in this total reaction here.
And these four hydroxide
molecules, anions,
well, they're going to be
used up in this second part
of the reactions.
So we're neutral there.
They get produced, but then they get used.
So if you look at the total reaction,
you're using the molecular
oxygen and the zinc
to produce zinc oxide.
And so they say use the
data in the table above,
calculate the cell potential
for the zinc-air cell.
Well, the potential for
this top reaction is zero,
is positive .34 volts.
And now what's the reaction,
what's the potential
for this bottom reaction?
Well, it's the reverse of this reaction,
so this reaction has a negative potential,
but since we reversed it, it's going to be
a positive potential.
So it's going to be positive 1.31 volts.
Now some of you might be saying,
well not only did we reverse
it, we multiplied it by two.
We said two of those
reactions, wouldn't we multiply
the voltage by two?
Well, if we were just
talking about the energy
released from a reaction,
well, yeah, absolutely.
If you're gonna have the
reaction twice or twice as much
of the reaction, you're
gonna have twice as much
of the energy.
But voltage, you have to remember,
you can view it as potential
energy per unit charge.
So since we're not, this isn't (mumbles)
absolute energy, this is
your energy per unit charge
is one way to think about it.
When you're doing more of it,
it doesn't change the actual voltage.
So that's an important
thing to think about.
If this was talking about
total energy or entropy
or something like that,
then if you were to multiply
both sides by two, you would
multiply the energy released
or taken by two.
But since we're talking about voltage,
voltage isn't a quantity
that depends on the number
of charges or the number of
molecules we're doing to,
it's a per.
It's what is the potential per unit charge
is one way to think about it.
And so for this whole
reaction, we would just add
the combined voltage of both of these,
and then you would get
1.65,
1.65 volts.
Now let's do part two.
The electrolyte paste
contains hydroxide ions.
On the diagram of the
cell above, draw an arrow
to indicate the direction of
migration of hydroxide ions
through the electrolyte
as a cell operates.
Well, we've already thought about that.
The hydroxide gets produced at the cathode
with this reaction, and then
it gets used up in the anode,
so the hydroxide is going to be moving,
the hydroxide is going to be moving
in that direction.